hello everyone as a lot of you have
requested this game here it is it's a
game from round one of the 2018
Sinquefield Cup we already saw a game
between Magnus Carlsen and Maxim for
sherrilyn Grove so here is a nice game
between Levin our onion and Sergey
Karjakin now before we check out the
game we do have a nice photo challenge
so best of luck to everyone it's a photo
from 2014 also from the scene field cup
there is 11 origin on the right but the
question is who is the gentleman on the
left
best of luck to everyone like I said and
along with the photo challenge we also
have a very nice photo of Magnus Carlsen
from the official a Grantchester Twitter
page there you have it it's a very nice
photo and they had like a little thing
they said you should caption this under
a Twitter page so I was very impressed
by it so indeed do capture this
following in the comments it's a very
strange what is Carson doing it's like
he has something written in his hand or
is he like should I use this hand to
crush my opponents or or perhaps the
other one but you know I'm only one
person there are many many many more of
you I'm sure you will be much more
creative than that so best of luck as
well with the photo challenge and
capturing this photo so let's get
straight into it sorry about that
yeah that's that's something I say for
later so efore by re n e5 Knight to f3
Knight to c6 and Bishop to b5 dual opus
on the board and everyone was very
impressed that Ariane went for efore
Knight to f6 the Berlin defense and here
as I already clicked it there you have
it the official arbiter of this
tournament Chris Burt tweeted I swear at
the players meeting we said no Berlin's
must be my accent so as to of the games
did go into a Berlin I don't think
anyone was paying attention to him or
perhaps he's only joking but ok we have
castles Knight captures on e4 we entered
the Rio gambit and now d4 grabbing this
pawn back immediately never proved to be
the lead to anything good for white so
there's no reason for anyone to do it
d4 was played and now Knight to d6
trying to grab
they spawn and keep your extra pawn runs
into rook to e1 and after d5 simply
Queen captures on d4 and it's white
White has plenty of compensation for
this extra pawn so this is a well-known
line 96 plate plenty of times the bishop
captures the D captures D captures on e5
Knight to f5 and now comes Queen
captures on the 8th King captures and
Knight to c3 King back to King back to
e8 we have a ch3 and now h4 h5 this
seems to be a new move soul perhaps
something kurakin is working on let's
see how onion prepared I'm not prepared
but rip life to it Bishop to g5 it's a
very nice diagonal and the bishop is
very its presence will be felt there on
g5 Bishop to e6 and now rook to d1
keeping a very nice keeping an eye on
that d8 square if this rook wasn't here
and then wrote to d8 I would be
checkmate you have to always keep an eye
for things like this nice to see three
and now rook to d2 preparing to double
up on the D file wrote the d8 rook
captures on d8 King after sandy 8 and
now rook to d1 we have King back to e8
and then now b3 as the bishop was eyeing
the a to pawn so now this Knight is free
to move h4 a very nice idea by karyakin
that allows this rook to enter the game
via rook to h5 so perhaps if Y played
something like this then ideas like
captures captures and rook for example
to h5 would be an idea
so Bishop to c1 in this position by
Aragon not allowing any such tricks
black still has the bishop pair but
until he really makes them you know
targets something they are not all that
powerful a5
we have nice to e2 rush up to d5 and now
comes nice to e 1 re maneuvering the
night goes back to e6 and now Knight to
f4 pressuring the bishop on e6 Bishop
goes back to c8 and now comes Knight to
f3 rook to h6 preparing to bring the
rook into the game we have
nice 2h2 trying to prove that the rook
isn't all that great here via Knight to
g4 so rook goes back as karkinos Ariane
is bringing the knife to g4 yes he does
he prepares an exchange nice to h6 we
have Knight back to e3 and now goes
Knight back to f5 again going for an
exchange
nice to see four again Ariane avoids the
exchange going for the a five point g5
first getting rid of the night we have
Knight back to e2 and now b6 defending
the a 5.92 d2 the night is no longer
useful and c4 so again Rima nuvaring
Knight to g7 Knight to e4 and now nice
to East 6 as g5 has been played now the
knife from e6 and the pond keep very
nicely ni on this F for square and here
we have Knight to f6 check the best move
in the position where black is pretty
much forced to give up his bishop pair
if you try something like King to f8
then you get nice to d4 Knight captures
rook captures and there's no good way to
defend the g5 pawn you would still have
to get rid of it and then go something
like rue g8 but it would be it would be
pointless to our white such activity so
might as well capture it right away but
should captures pawn captures and now
Rock to g8 you have to defend the g5
point f3 rope to g6 attacking the f6
pawn and here Bishop to b2 defending the
f6 pawn push up to d7 and now nice to
see one yet again Romano ring with the
knight c5 and now comes Bishop to e5
King to d8 we have Knight 2 D 3 and now
King to see it and here we have a
beautiful maneuvering idea by Aragon if
for example if you play something like
King to have to here bringing it start
started bringing your King into the game
and then you will run into this knife to
d4 move that will prevent your Bishop
from going backwards and now you do have
to do something for example it's a very
nice square for the knight the c2 point
is under attack if you push it away
Knight to c6 is coming your Bishop is
under attack and you have
no squares left for your Bishop I mean
you do you can go Bishop to H do but
then you've left this F six pawn
unguarded rook captures and you just
lost the pawn so here are young gets a
beautiful idea he plays Bishop back to
be two and I say this is a beautiful
idea because now this Knight d4 idea
that prevents this Bishop from guarding
the f6 pawn runs into Knight to e5 and
now you can't really capture it I mean
you have to but it's not all that great
after you capture you get Knight
captures here and now you cannot
recapture because you get c3 and you
lose the night for example King capture
c3 the knight is pinned so you will lose
a piece here but instead you have to go
rook to d6 defend the night here but and
prevent this knife from escaping but
white still has an answer rope captures
here C captors and now ninety five and a
knight and the bishop will be will be
better than this lonely rook even d3 is
impossible because the knight is
guarding it so after this Bishop to b2
move Bishop to ei tis played not
allowing just 95 captures on d7 idea
rook to e1 again you cannot move the
knight as the bishop is now unguarded I
would have looked to g8 another rogue
has to guard the Bishop rook to e4 and
now King to d8 we have King to f2 and
the knight to f/8 and now you can see
how with this shrewd maneuvering
re-enforced kurakin to push all of his
pieces and the King to the back rank
also I will probably most probably use
this for the thumbnail so nice t5 a very
nice move centralizing the knight Knight
2h7 attacking the f6 pawn and now f4
again a beautiful move by Aragon not
allowing this pawn on f6 to be captured
G Capra's on f4 seems to be the best
idea here Knight captures isn't all that
great because it runs into Knight
captures on f7 with check so you don't
have time to capture White's rook with
the check you have to capture the night
now comes some bunch of captures with
check King moves and now have captures
on g5 the bishop is on f6 so the pawn on
d5 is guarded a very nice position for
white white gets even gets an extra pawn
and this
four points on the dark square so it's a
very weak point you will not be able to
defend it so after a four rook to h8
displayed by Hurricane Andrew now comes
Knight to f3 pressuring the g5 point F
cap G captors on f4 we have rook
captures on f4 and now tonight back to a
fate again the knight is forced to do a
backwards rank rook captures on h4
grabbing upon rook captures Knight
captures and now Bishop to c6 and okay
white is now up a pawn but if the
Knights are exchanged the bishops are of
opposite colors so perhaps the black can
hold to this King to e3
arianna improves the position of his
King and now King to d7 kirkin does the
same g4 and now comes Knight to g6 here
kurakin offers a trade of knights saying
that he will be able to hold it this
opposite color Bishop endgame upon down
and Aragon says no you know you don't
even though the engine prefer you know
really prefers this Knight to f5 move
Aragon says you will not be able to hold
this F capture Sun g6 is played and now
comes Bishop to e5 and here are in and
shows why this is great because black
has no good answer to Bishop captures on
c7 I might also use this as a thumbnail
it's hard to say
so this is a threat and of course if
even if you play something like rush up
to d5 now preventing this as the bishop
is already guarding the f7 squared then
you allow king of King here to here and
it's it's all over so after this Bishop
to e5 move Kerrigan started his own
expansion on the Queen side this of
course allows the Bishop captures here
now you you're not allowed to capture
the bishop because there's no stopping
this pawn now and a 4 we have the first
Bishop to b6
attacking the c5 pawn but now pawn
captures here pawn captures here and now
g5 there was no point in playing
something like c4 because after four
captures captures now okay you black has
a passed pawn but it's not very useful
Westbourne black can't keep an eye on
the pawns on the King side and the
passed pawn on the Queen side
so after C capture son b3 g5 was played
Bishop captures on c5 and now King T
we have dr. D for worship - G - now
attacking the h3 porn so also a very
nice exercise feel free to pause the
video here and find the winning idea for
white or an idea that will lead to a
winning position for white and just you
know if you're faced with this Bishop -
G - move in a blitz game you have to
play something you have to know what to
play I will give it a second for it to
the side of course and for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
you are an excellent end game player and
especially and an opposite colored
bishops and game player and for those of
you just one enjoyed show h4 is the idea
which is funny because you know H
forests are again signature move G
captors on h4 and now kink - a for
preparing to meet this h3 move with King
to g3 so okay King to f7 we have g5 now
and we have h3 King has to go to g3 to
protect him to guard against the pond to
pond - h2 King goes to g6 and now birth
of 3:3 guarding the g5 pawn here King
goes back to f7 Bishop to d2 now we have
King back to g6 and now as White is up
on Bishop is nicely placed on D - so
this was never even an option a4
captures captures re on creates a passed
pawn on the Queen side as well in the
now King to f7 a 5 we have rush up to f1
you have to protect this point from ever
reaching the a light square Bishop to f4
and then outcomes came back to g6 King
to g4 was played here King to f7 King
here now of course the threat is even g6
so you have to prevent this rush to d3
with check King moves and now Bishop
goes back and here white is completely
winning there is nothing to do here
a couple of more moves were played King
d6 we had Bishop to d3 now comes king c5
and it was in this in this position on
move 69 that circuit cutter can resigned
at the game as you can see this point
can never go forward as the bishop is
guarding the dark square and the king
will simply after something like King e6
has played the king is coming to b6 and
now there is no stopping a6 whatever you
play a 6 is coming to
have to give up the bishop and now the
winning plan is pretty simple the bishop
is still guarding the h2 pawn you will
simply March your king over to f5 pull
g6 push g7 you know and win the game or
f7 and check with the bishop and you
know the you know how it goes so yeah
that's the game a very nice victory for
eleven Iranian and kirkin was unable to
prevent him from reaching a full point
even by using the brilliant defense
which as we can see was not allowed as
the official arbiter you know hell
forbid it so yeah that's the video
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
and that you're enjoying the coverage of
the 2018 Sinquefield Cup I would like to
thank in Johnson and algal matters dog
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check - all my previous
videos here thank you all for watching
and I will see you soon we have a very
nice video planned for this evening it's
a it's a it's a scandal that you know
really caught it the chess world by
surprise some 10 years ago I'm sure
you'll enjoy it and for the end of this
video let's enjoy another photo of
Jeanie and Rex Sinquefield presenting
Maxime for sherrilyn Grove with his big
fat check from last year which shows
that if you are a really good player you
can even you know make a living by
actually playing chess so thank you all
and I will see you soon